after the Intrigue and scheming of the
first volume Vol 2 of the third season
of Netflix's The Witcher brings the pain
here's how things shook out in these
continent shattering episodes
after yennefer geralt and Siri escape
from the clutches of the wild Hunt at
the end of season two the show turns its
focus to Siri's Journey it seems as
though everyone from rodania to aratuza
is out to get her with each group
harboring their own reasons for why Siri
can benefit their plans
Siri herself is struggling with her
innate power trying and failing to wield
her abilities under Jennifer's guidance
she's eventually able to start her
journey towards magical greatness
successfully taking down a fearsome sea
creature much to the Delight of geralt
you adapted at every turn
I'm proud of you Siri yennefer and
geralt meanwhile take on a different
significance this time as a couple
as the White Flame tries to form an
uneasy alliance with the elves by using
kahir as a mouthpiece Jennifer enlists
the help of tasaya to host a conclave of
Mages at aratuza in the name of
promoting peace their suspicion before
the night even arrives with all parties
gaining on series whereabouts meanwhile
yaskir gets closer to Prince radovid as
an unlikely romance seems to Blossom
the conclave of Mages turns into a
full-blown Siege of aratuza and the
stakes are dramatically raised geralt
spends most of the final episode of the
Season healing from his fearsome battle
with bilgeforts Jennifer pays him a
visit while he takes Refuge under the
care of the dryads leading to a tender
moment that suggests that they're
definitely a couple
of forts reappears when news of the
White Plain capturing Series starts to
spread Amir appears to marry his own
daughter but the catch is that this Siri
isn't actually Siri at all she's Taryn
the young girl subjected to mind control
Magic In The Season's second episode not
only does this mean huge changes for the
White Flame himself but it significantly
Alters things for those around him his
uneasy alliance with the elves threatens
to unravel after Francesca learns what
actually happened to her baby
murdered my child the real Siri turns up
as a hostage at a bar in the middle of
nowhere meanwhile Jennifer tries to take
control of things at aratusa after to
say is death King vizimir is killed
leading Prince radovid to be crowned as
part of philippa's grand plan ending any
chance of him running off with the
askier
The Witcher has never been too hot on
its treatment of female characters in
season 3 carries on that tradition to
say a story is probably the saddest
struggling to live with herself after
her actions at the siege of aratuza
dasaya decides to take her own life
leaving yennefer to find her along with
her reaction to finding out about
bilgafor it's deceit to say his demise
doesn't feel fitting to her character
she's been deemed the most powerful
sorceress throughout the kingdoms so her
crumbling to the first sign of fault
isn't befitting of the Legacy she has
supposedly cultivated the same can be
said for plenty of the show's other
secondary female characters most of whom
have stayed in the shadows until it's
too late the season finale only just
begins to hint at philippa's true
intentions and Powers while Francesca is
left to fall from the grace of being a
feared and Powerful leader the only
woman who possibly comes away from the
finale in a better place is Siri who's
learning to channel a form of magic that
she didn't really know existed within
her
one of the highlights throughout season
3 is the unexpected romance between
yaskir and Prince radovid after an
initial meeting yes gear is invited to a
party where he performs a song in front
of the prince leading radovid to become
enamored with him juggling his
attraction with his allegiance to geralt
in responsibility protecting Siri yes
gear dubiously explores his feelings
this eventually leads him to believe
that radovid is setting him up for
failure by the time the season finale
rolls around the hope for their romance
is cruelly dashed by being crowned king
of rodania radovid is unable to fulfill
his desire of taking off with yaskir
unwittingly falling into a trap Philippa
has set for him
though this makes for a great plot twist
in the episode's closing moments the
decision could potentially do damage to
the positive queer representation in The
Witcher so far yaskir and radovid's
relationship has felt very true to life
messy confusing and fueled by a passion
that the pair often feel needs to be
hushed if their romance isn't handled
sensitively heading into season 4 the
show risks undoing all the work that it
has done so far surprisingly the
character that has the least Fanfare in
the season 3 finale is the main man
himself the season began with geralt's
role shifting from being the focus on
the action to aiding series growth he
chooses to leave care more and in favor
of a safe house he becomes instrument
mental in series journey to discover the
extent of her magic powers and likewise
Works alongside yennefer to try and
uncover vilgafort's for who he truly is
in short he hasn't done much on his own
and the season finale shows his
storyline tapering off Into Obscurity
after his battle with the village
reports geralt spends episodes 7 and 8
recuperating from his injuries with the
dryads he makes a notable recovery as
the season closes and heads off to try
and set things right
the trouble is we never get to see what
this might be which is a strange
decision given that this was Henry
cavill's last turn in the role the lack
of emphasis on geralt's story might be a
way to take attention away from the
forthcoming casting change allowing Liam
Hemsworth to almost slip in unnoticed
another Cornerstone of The Witcher is
the on-again off-again romance between
geralt and yennefer season 3 arguably
turns the certainty up a notch with the
events of the conclave of Mages all but
confirming their pairing as a couple
however the show's penchant for keeping
them apart kicks back in during the
closing episodes with Jennifer becoming
preoccupied with the order of aratuza it
could be argued that each has a path
ahead of them that's more important than
being together with the universe set to
take over for taseo while geralt tries
to take down bilgefort single-handedly
for the greater good of The Witcher
world this is what viewers might expect
to happen however geralt and yennefer
also seemed Bound by an unspoken Destiny
just like geralt in Syria
last time let's see positioning
themselves as a family unit the trio
have outwardly promised to find their
way back to each other numerous times
that said Siri's New Journey of
self-discovery might mean that this
becomes more difficult to season 4
progressives
by the end of The Season's fifth episode
the Brotherhood is already in a
precarious State during the conclave of
Mages geralt and yennefer become
convinced that stregabore is the mole in
the Brotherhood and successfully
convinced the other members of his guilt
it soon becomes clear that it is in fact
vilgafort's though and the organization
is already deeply compromised this gets
worse as the siege of aratuza takes hold
killing off key members including
Artorias during battle to make matters
worse tusaya takes her own life leaving
the Brotherhood without a highly
influential leader something season 4 is
likely to look at is how the Brotherhood
can bounce back from the chaos if it
even can little trust is left with the
glue that could keep things together
likely to be the combined power and
unity of geralt and Jennifer the Mages
of aratuza are likely to take more
control having remained a strong unit
through season three's deceptions and
tribulations Tris is undeniably by
Jennifer's side while frangela's
reappearance could strengthen the group
even further
one of the most surprising twists in the
season 3 finale is series fate all
season long fans have watched her
struggle with her lack of control over
her abilities unable to cultivate any
real magic under yennefer's guidance
after she gets separated from Jennifer
and geralt Siri finds herself in the
core at the desert with seemingly No Way
Out while she's there she meets a
strange woman who implies that Siri has
more power than she knows who later
turns out to be called falca falca is
the eldest child of King rydank who also
is born with Elven blood she started a
rebellion that led to many deaths
including most of her own family I took
back what was rightfully mine in the
finale's closing moments Siri tells a
stranger to call her falca suggesting
that the two characters are about to
merge into one given that falca is
considered to be a historical evil Ceres
Newfound sense of power will perhaps now
take her down a more villainous path
now that the second war has officially
begun there's a lot that is up for grabs
in the season 3 finale the White Flame
makes it clear that he believes himself
to hold the most power with vilgafort
standing proudly by his side for the
time being this might actually be the
case much of the surrounding Kingdom
either fears or respects him with his
immediate enemies and threats currently
down for the count however this isn't
likely to last for long now that geralt
is back to full health season 4 is
likely to show him on the war path to
Justice and Redemption vilgaforts will
be his main target given their earlier
battle but if geralt learns of amir's
marriage to the fake Siri he'll be out
for the White Flame too at the same time
other deceits and acts of power grabbing
can't be ruled out either newly crowned
King radovid will be out to seek
Vengeance for his recently deceased
brother especially if he doesn't learn
the truth that Philippa was responsible
the wild Hunt is beginning to once again
rear its head after a lengthy Hiatus
while the Brotherhood is on the verge of
reassembling this is all before we even
consider Siri who is set to wreak havoc
on those she loves the most thanks to
falca's influence
Henry cavill's exit from the show was
announced back in October 2022 and it
was made clear that the third season
would be his last in a statement on his
Instagram profile Cavill wrote as with
the greatest of literary characters I
passed the torch with reverence for the
time spent in body and geralt and
enthusiasm to see Liam's take on this
Most Fascinating and nuanced of man
cabell's involvement with the show or
lack thereof is the most telling factor
for what might happen next showrunner
Lauren Schmidt his Rick elaborated on
geralt's fate in an interview with total
film stating that the writers initially
had other Alternatives in mind she said
it was time for him in his life to move
on I think we've all been mourning this
in our own way we had the choice to have
geralt exit and to end the show but
that's not something that we were
willing to do there's just too many
stories left to tell cast member Joey
Beatty also remarked that Cavill leaving
the show was bittersweet during an
interview with on-demand entertainment
he added of cavil he brings such a
professionalism such a respect
and laughter to the self the Netflix
version of The Witcher has often been
compared to its original Source material
in the books and the video game
adaptations for season 3 The keyframe of
reference is the novel The Time of
contempt there have already been some
noticeable changes that could be
indicators of where the TV show will end
up next this means that the writers of
the show can really spin the story off
in a new direction as in the books
Philippa plays a key role in vizimir's
assassination and the subsequent changes
to rodania's government we're likely to
see her character greatly expanded
another key part of season 3's ending is
aratuza which now faces a complete
overhaul following the attack on the
school likewise Amir marries a fake Siri
much later in the books in the novel The
Lady of the Lake advancing that plot
element is sure to shake things up too
[Music]